as you guys finished this landmark
picture what would you take away from
this what was the what was the thing
each of you learned that was maybe the
biggest change that you learn about how
you work how your work has changed
certainly I think with gravity you can
work on something you can work on
something you can make you really had
the best that it could possibly be and
then you turned out to work the next day
and you think actually that could be
better and you can do it again and you
can keep on going and because we did
have some time I you know on the film in
the end we were able to keep pushing
ourselves and we were literally we were
limited by our own stamina had to do
that and that's certainly something I'd
take away I think when you mentioned the
time I think that was a big factor but I
think another big factor for us was that
the whole production was based in the
same building we had Alfonso in his
office was on the same floor David
Heyman the client production the art
department editorial so there was an
amazing collaborative effort and
symbiotic everything evolved together
and we've everybody was pushing
everybody else and that immediate flow
of information and communication really
seems big factor in in the way the film
turned out that we did so much the
collaborative aspect of the movie was a
really big part for me and the fact that
everyone was based in the building at
frames towards part of that but also the
fact that we were working on a sort of
movie that had never been done before
and having to develop all these new
techniques and and also develop new ways
for the departments to work together and
you know so because we were having to
develop new ways to work together we all
ended up working much more closely
together i mean the visual effects and
editing and we've spoken about visual
effects and cinematography and
production design were all you know we
had members of the production design
department sitting with visual effects
artists doing set dressing because it
was a virtual set and I think that was a
massive part of it you know I mean there
there are many tools and techniques we
developed on this movie that are already
being used on other movies
well I'm sure we'll be used in the
future not as a whole because you know
as a whole they apply to have a very
particular type of movie set in space I
suppose but many of the individual
elements so that that's all great but I
think that you know that collaboration
and the time in preparation is I think
what enabled all those other techniques
and tools to be developed for the human
artist this is a movie that was a real
landmark collaboration of techniques it
would it was like a live-action movie it
was like a visual effects movie it was
like an animated movie it defies all of
those categorizations it really is I
think the movie that will stand as one
that has really broken through all those
things it's a different kind of
filmmaking and and the greatest thing
about it everyone it's all done it's a
great movie and people love